bien
cuando me invitaron a actuar en un té de
equis tx santa rosa lo primero que
pregunté fue cuánto tiempo tengo no hay
tiempo me dijeron que como que no hay
tiempo no no hay tiempo simplemente
respondieron sin embargo yo necesito
tomarme el tiempo para ciertas cosas que
considero fundamentales como por ejemplo
está
ahora sí estaba como medio
[Aplausos]
me quedé con esto que me dijeron que no
hay tiempo
el tiempo sí desde que nacemos entramos
en su flujo lo medimos lo marcamos pero
no podemos desafiarlo no podemos
acelerar lo que desacelerar o sí
entonces ahí si decimos que no hay
tiempo que el tiempo es una percepción
que no es real que es una medida
inventada por el ser humano llegó tarde
llegó rápido llegó lento es una
percepción
han tenido la sensación de que un día
gris aburrido parece durar más de 24
horas
o que un momento de felicidad dura tan
sólo un instante no les gustaría que ese
instante se congele en el tiempo
o incluso más
retroceder en el tiempo
y hacer que ese instante se pueda volver
a repetir sería mágico verdad
me resulta un poco extraño que haya un
mago en un evento ted al menos así lo
veo yo
las personas que actuaron antes que yo
de alguna u otra manera tienen un
sustento científico y la magia es
justamente todo lo contrario
más que viene del latín que a su vez
viene del griego y significa ser capaz
ser capaz de desafiar las leyes de la
naturaleza y eventualmente pensarlas
pero para que exista una magia primero
hay que creer así que quiero invitarlos
a todos ustedes esta tarde a que sientan
vivan y crean en la magia me acompañan
muchas gracias
para el primer efecto voy a necesitar la
colaboración de un caballero el muchacho
que está con la camisa a cuadros como es
tu nombre
davis te animas a pasar por favor un
fuerte aplauso para david
voy a ver que te ubiques aquí te voy a
saludar como estás hábito igualmente y
la vida
en mi bolsillo tengo cartas de póker
creo que me sostenga por favor no lo
dejes ahí arriba de la mesa estaría
tréboles corazones picas diamantes
correcto bien perfecto vamos a mezclar
hace un poquito la vida vas a elegir una
cualquiera
la vas a mirar la vas a mostrar a todo
el público
y la vas a firmar en la cara a la vida
es decir donde tiene el dibujo
estamos haciendo que tu carta sea una
carta totalmente diferente del resto es
algo que hayas tomado alguna carta con
anterioridad justo el día de hoy sería
una casualidad que yo la tenga sin
embargo ponerle tu firma va a hacer que
sea capaz sea totalmente diferente listo
david bien perfecto pero mira lo que voy
a hacer es la voy a perder más o menos
en la mitad del mazo ok para toda la
gente está viendo también estoy a pedir
por favor que revises la caja que
compruebes que la caja queda
completamente vacía
está vacía la caja de ávila vamos a
mezclar las cartas y voy a colocar
permitir en la caja voy a colocar todas
las cartas incluidas la tuya que está
firmada e identificada dentro de la caja
voy a pedir que revise en mi bolsillo
derecho para controlar está
completamente vacío
está vacío yo voy a colocar todas las
cartas dentro de la caja que está
cerrada adentro de mi bolsillo que está
completamente vacío lo que va a suceder
ahora es lo siguiente
yo voy a sacar la caja la voy a abrir
voy a buscar entre todas las cartas del
dorso porque la tuya está firmada si no
va a ser muy fácil encontrarlas voy a
encontrar la tuya la voy a colocar sobre
tu mano porque te voy a pedir que
coloques la mano de esta manera
cualquiera de las dos perfecto
voy a juntar el resto de las cartas las
voy a volver a meter adentro de la caja
voy a cerrar la caja y nuevamente voy a
colocar la caja dentro de mi bolsillo
sería posible decir que yo haga esto en
3 segundos
crees que no empecé a contar 123 fíjate
que yo saqué la carta y la caja está
nuevamente cerrada
la vida de 12 corazones es un regalo
para vos puedes volver a terminar muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
paradójicamente hablando del tiempo
este truco es posible porque existen
distintas percepciones del tiempo
y el truco que viene a continuación no
tuve tiempo de prepararla
les voy a decir algo que no debería
decir pero estoy acá y lo voy a decir lo
digo
los magos compramos trucos lo dije
en la realidad me llamaron para un
evento usted es algo totalmente
diferente quería hacer algo diferente
compré un truco en el exterior los
tiempos que maneja la aduana no son los
mismos tiempos que yo
me llegó hoy a la mañana
no tuve tiempo de prepararlo pero nada
ya estaba pautado lo tengo que hacer
igual que va a pasar la realidad a usted
no salgan en cuenta en esto pero los
truco vienen con instrucciones solo las
instrucciones lo hago tiene que salir me
acompañen por favor
hay algún docente en la sala por aquí
cerca nadie como es tu nombre
romina me podrías acompañar por favor un
fuerte aplauso para romina
romina es docente entonces va a leer las
instrucciones de forma didáctica así
tenemos aquí las instrucciones del fuego
nominativas o de cara y ésta es perfecta
el micrófono de mano si está por ahí no
está por ejemplo vas a tener que modular
los docentes estás acostumbrada y bien
el micrófono de manos para ver
ahí hay otro mira a falta de uno
bien sí
retirar 6 listo
a
al público para elegir un espectador
cómo
arroz de martillo al público para elegir
un espectador
no
es de goma
hay bien muchas gracias
muchas gracias
y lo guarda
reciban con una ovación el espectador
que sube al escenario
retira los celulares y sobre el maletín
como tu nombre
no es más fácil imposible
celulares y sobres de el maletín para
los hombres y los celulares
cómo se mira
por favor simplemente que realice los
sobres que están vacíos hacia el tacto
que son sobres comunes
respecto de los celulares entre sus
manos
como con las cartas
pasando metiendo un celular
cerca
por qué inventar algo para la próxima
para esta parte
venimos bien romina
por eso
coloca un celular dentro de casa sobre
decía
[Música]
si vos tenés una enzima bueno
alguien que tenga perfecto como es tu
nombre rosa romina te voy a decir
está bien
vea simplemente cambiarlos de lugar de
poner ahí alguno y arriba es lo mismo si
tenéis más lugar más espacio yo no voy a
ver al celular de romina que está dicen
está de la gente
bien perfecto
probablemente romina romina o romina
haya visto dónde queda el celular del
espectador entonces quiero que cierre
sus ojos a ustedes vuelta de manera que
se pueda mezclar lo y vos no puedas
notar
cuál es tu celular ok
no
perfecto como sigue
perfecto al número 1 qué número le vamos
a poner sr
número uno abajo se pone más aquí
señor me caso muy bien al número 22
ay
al número 3
ah
al número 4 querer cambiar
una rebelde
una persona que está a tu derecha al
número 5 que no me lo quiere poner
y la última el último que nos queda es
el guau
perfecto
bien cómo sigue esto
bien
espectador por favor domina sobre la
mesa
romina
si hace terapia no
se trataría con gas natural del lado
bueno para 6 lo vamos a separar
vamos a dejarlo por aquí 6 qué hacemos
con el 6
soy plantel sobre selección
ah
me gusta la acción hasta que quede solo
un sobre
si esto es en la instrucción por favor
romina arroja helado
romina no está causando muchas gracias
ah
ya salió nuevamente
tenés ganas
nuevo con ganas de más
bueno
i
señala me uno
una vez
pero en un iphone
era un iphone
de camps y tenemos un poco lo que
sucedió hasta ahora
no me no subió a leer las instrucciones
romina en mezcló los sobres romina
mezcló los celulares romina colocó los
celulares adentro de los sobres romina
nos presta un celular para colocarla
dentro de un sobre
romina y alguno más número nos sobre
romina tiene un dado y si se animal de
quien va será culpa
ahora sí como si recibe el celular que
quedó y compruebe del espectador para
recibirlos
retire el celular que quedó y compruebe
que es el espectador
[Aplausos]
muchísimas gracias
gracias domina
muchas gracias romina
y muchas gracias ramita
bien
para el siguiente efecto de la buscar un
espectador
como es tu nombre si graciela gracia te
animas a participar un fuerte aplauso
por favor para graciela
cuando declara que la salud
vamos a colocar la guía
a mi derecha gracias a lo que vamos a
hacer ahora es algo que se hacía un
tiempo atrás y que nos hacía muy felices
te gustan las cartas si bien hoy vamos a
escribir una
mira
lo que tengo eso aquí son cartas de
póker ya las vimos
creo les corazones picas diamantes vamos
a elegir rápidamente una cualquiera
perfecto la vas a mirar
tras colocar vamos un poquito más
adelante en el problema la vas a mostrar
al público
bien es importante que el público la
recuerde es importante que es la veas
también y que vos la recuerdas permitirá
si es importante que vos las recuerden
es importante que el público la recuerde
es importante que yo no la vea pero
también es importante que recuerden el
color de la carta sí
para marcarla esta carta para hacerla
diferente vamos a cortar una esquinita
así la verdad
así la vas a tener y la vas a guardar un
bolsillo de los bolsillos y bien
perfecto y la carta la vas a tener en la
mano también
lo que vamos a hacer yo dije que vamos a
mandar una carta entonces para mandar
una carta que necesitamos un favor
en un sobre por aquí que dice para manu
sereno que soy yo mi dirección juan
b.justo 101 noveno b remitente mago k en
general savio 800 o sea k
al abordar adentro
3 de diamantes que les falta una esquina
y le vamos a mandar es una carta adentro
de una carta
necesitamos una estampilla perfecto pero
para eso yo traje aquí
las estampillas de correos fíjate que
tengo varias de varios pesos de varios
equipos si vas a cerrar los ojos vas a
meter la mano y va a salir de ahí sólo
un visto perfecto cuales 25 centavos
tiene una figura de un ficus le vamos a
mostrar a la gente como si lo pudiera
medir el de atrás créame que es un
fútbol
vamos a dejar ir de momento y la vamos a
pegar
para eso traje
juan b.justo ciento 19 no es como si
fuese el consultorio de una polis está
yo tendría que vivir más bien en la
calle tipo del vidente alguien que sea
vidente como por ejemplo raúl ve días
es un tema de las calles
porque también está carlos que tomaba
vino de mendoza y marcelo t de alvear
elegiste una estampilla al azar y elegir
una carta al azar le cortamos una
esquinita y la vamos a enviar por correo
la vamos a enviar en una urna
alguien dijo alguna vez que el tiempo es
lo que se tarda en ir de un lugar a otro
pero si anteriormente dijimos que no hay
tiempo quiere decir que podemos estar en
unos lugares a la vez
podemos estar aquí en el presente pero
también podemos estar en el futuro
pasado presente y futuro en una misma
línea y conviviendo o sea que si yo
quisiera saber lo que pasó con tu carta
simplemente tendría que comunicarme con
mi hijo del futuro
y eso es lo que vamos a hacer un
poquitito más a la derecha y vamos a
comunicarnos con visual futuro
[Música]
o la mano cómo estás
si las tripas a una genial
bueno estoy acá con graciela te llegó la
carta
pero no sos vos hermano del futuro
el futuro
y
no entendí
[Música]
esperemos que sea así porque yo estoy
acá con la gente mira si no es que
tenemos que hacer de pifia de tiempo
ojalá que sea sino no sé de qué nación
25 centavos
correcto
que tiene un ficus y tiene un ficus y se
puede ver el pico
[Aplausos]
que tiene
la tiene guardada graciela en su
bolsillo
ah
3 de diamante correctoras y las 3 de
diamantes
3 de diamantes
nuevas elecciones
dale dale
no es
me parece que el mérito para vos
igual
además escribió una carta con
a escribir una carta literal
está escribiendo una carta que está
escribiendo en tres diamantes lo está
escribiendo
sólo por creer yo acá pintado dibujado y
él son buenos es hoy son realidad pero
está escribiendo una carta
con cariño con cariño y buenísimo
buenísimo cómo se la va a llegar a
graciela como hacemos
no
en una misma línea y conviviendo tengo
que disfrutar
cómo te vas
o sea
se fue
pasado presente y futuro en una misma
línea y conviviendo
eso quiere decir que tu carta
vamos a buscar abril
ahora está tu carta cocina
este
vamos a abrirlo
le falta una esquina
es el 3 de diamantes está firmada la
gente no puede creer
con cariño mago kn y le falta una
esquina y vos tenés una esquina en tu
bolsillo de la carta que elegiste vos
inicialmente permitimos que casualidad
que esa esquina coincide exactamente
gracias muchísimas gracias puedes quedar
del agua que arde el sobre también
qué loco esto
del tiempo porque ya casi estamos
llegando al final
tengo que dejar las cosas como estaban
inicialmente
el tiempo es lo más valioso que tiene el
ser humano dar tiempo es garantía de
recibir lo mismo el tiempo de los demás
en ese tiempo vamos a vivir los mejores
momentos de nuestras vidas porque estos
se tejen junto a las personas y también
junto a nosotros mismos
por eso quien te regala tiempo
te está dando algo que
jamás recuperará por eso el tiempo es un
regalo divino
disfrutemos ese tiempo
miremos a los ojos destruyamos celulares
reencontremos todavía si estamos a
tiempo
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias es un placer estar acá
gracias
[Aplausos]